you should keep Griffin here on the
Richardson show how you doing cheeky oh
come on
any time there's always there's always a
space here for you three days removed
what are your thoughts going through
your mind right now
oh it's been crazy especially being back
home and you know interacting on there
but it's just been it's been crazy and
he sees how many people are so happy
that me my brother and he kept asking
what's the weight worth it and I
definitely say the way was worth it I
mean obviously it was a it was a rough
rough three days but you know I
definitely weighed all over again
opportunity without my brother and I'm
so glad that I'm able to you know house
pass so that was always gonna ask you is
if you regretted being in the green room
Thursday and Friday night at all she saw
it definitely I mean I said experience
that a lot of people can't say they did
you know I'm glad I'm being able to
experience that we get the home sitting
before my brother and you know game that
hasn't had opportunity green room yeah
everything is ran I mean you can't ask
for more maybe being a me being a kid
growing up watching how how it's done
you know watching from TV is definitely
differently you don't want to sin
deciding room but when it was all said
and done do you think you would have
felt this way even if you were not
drafted and reunited with your brother
as teammates she came I mean you won't
know unless it happened I know I was
1,000 definitely saying you know I said
you know obviously seeing guys in front
of me being picked and guys they picked
over me and earlier around
you know I was you can always feel some
type of way but you know you when you
get something that you always want out
of life and number one was all the time
you know it got the guy had things
planned for a reason and everything I
was for a reason
you know me falling back in later around
something I pretend to be yeah I think
was the perfect and happening it seemed
like he was supposed to be like that and
it seemed like everything that's been
going on it's just like it is falling in
place and I'm just glad that I'm able to
you know be in feedback and reunited
with my brother you know it'll be great
things coming soon okay I know that
Seattle is excited for a minute of
course I'll be excited for me it's gonna
be like great things happening I mean
I'm excited to fly up on Thursday yeah
so that's what I guess that's gonna say
you're gonna go Thursday
you go and then you moving in with your
brother
you guys gonna be roommates too gonna be
roommates in the first you ladies I'm
staying and I'm staying the hotel with
the regular stuff I want to get
activated with them and sure no you know
who they are and stuff and you know
that's a relationship that is gonna be
not gonna be forever you know especially
yeah got you coming in with you know
that's a relationship that you want to
be able to you know experience in half
with those guys so I'm definitely gonna
have my video game and stuff at my
brother's house I'm definitely gonna go
by the house and see him and I'll get my
room set up but you know definitely go
there first few days they get acclimated
with the rookie is he gonna make you pay
rent see team talk about it I mean baby
first ones I can get free we'll see how
it goes okay just want to make sure so
who have you heard from who have you
heard from over the last three days that
might be of interest to fans of yours
that you were thrilled to have heard
from now that you got drafted in the NFL
I mean then the next day I met Lil Wayne
so that was Lil Wayne called yeah that
was really awesome to talk to I forgot
my person so that was pretty cool he
talked to me you know yeah then he gave
me some words inspiration about you know
mission I stay focused stay humble you
know there's only the beginning and
stuff and he uh he took each of the kids
about me all the time and you know just
to hear things like that from him and
you you just never know who's watching
and it's just it's kind of cool you know
that kind of had that talk with him and
you know you just give you that extra
motivation before I leave yeah stay
humble that's interesting because that's
a phrase that I heard Pete Carroll tell
you in the phone conversation that the
Seahawks tweeted out how do you stay
humble I mean we've got you there
remember what you what you're doing this
for and you know I you understand that I
didn't play football too because you
know it can be always that you can get
paid you know that's my reason why I
play football because I love it and I've
been told so many times that I couldn't
play and not have the opportunity to
play it make it mine you know make it my
job I mean the best things in the world
and I'm not always gonna remember where
I came from I'm always gonna remember
know what hard work you know gets me in
you know I'm on
really stick with me people that doubted
me in the mall so I'm also had a chip in
my shoulder I mean I don't I don't have
that red copper set for me where I can
just you know you walk out there be on
the team and they get everything handed
to me by work favorite thing I have
about a Walkman do you think I wanna do
she came Griffin here on the retired
show do you think you were fairly
evaluated as a football player in the
draft no I mean definitely not I mean it
is what it is I mean obviously I knew
that especially you saw come down to the
point where they make no big decisions a
lot of things might feel like you know
they they've taken a chance that no
grabbing me but I'm glad you see how
that was clean I took that chance with
me and you know they got a time in the
roughing all I know is you know your
line of scouts will tell the kids and
you may you know win games played hard
put on it Uncle Phil no be a good care
of the kid make sure you know everything
is on and off the field you know work
hard you know do everything when it
comes when you're singing a bow you know
straight your face you know what your
part off and separate yourself from
others do well at the compound you know
stay focused stay humble and keep
working in you know you can work your
way up
I mean I did everything on the things
and they said win games I want every
single one when they say play hard I
play hard I put on good film I ran my
butt up then when they say you know to
clear things off the field I always did
you know always made sure that I stayed
in it the straight road for me to be
good on and off the field
they said well the Senior Bowl and if
airplanes got in I did that and got MVP
at the Senior Bowl they say too that the
compound I did that and everybody look
on in a compound
I checked off every single box that I
was told to and then I was I was
evaluated separately from everybody else
was like well he did everything we're
talking to but Kenny really handle
everything and then in the next and next
level and they're all gonna be that
question you know I know he's long
something I doubt that that's why you
know I'm here I got opportunity to build
a great team okay call your stuff and
I'm late to quit Dallas to rest you
heard from Russell Wilson we chatted
with him yet I haven't chat with him yet
you know I will so mm-hmm okay and
you're going up there and I'm just
wondering she keen what the five year
old six-year-old Shekinah Griffin
would think knowing what the current
version knows well it probably starts to
fall for one but no me being a young
guys I would never even imagine meet me
in the situation I mean obviously me
looking at the draft and me being young
kid you know obviously every kid you
know when the teacher that what you want
to be when you grow up and you say a
football player you know that's a long
road from where you left and you just
never know how it's gonna play out but
I'm glad I stayed focused
I can't work my butt off him you know
it'd be crazy to tell my fire girls up
and she'll be here one day and you know
there's only the beginning though he's a
just an egg it's just the next chapter
of my life and I'm ready to catch up to
everything I have and then what's your
goals for what year one what do you got
for me
my year wanted this to contribute the
best where I can and be a guy who can
who can bring his team up no matter what
I feel I want to be a culture change and
I want to be able to be a guy with mana
energy no matter what I want to be a guy
looking to help out no matter what
position he played no matter what
scheming in I want to pick up who
coaches know when I'm in comedy I got
everything I want I want to be a guy we
can change the game just what he's doing
and you know from alone from a long time
I was going back I got some long career
in the league again you know change
lives I mean I think that's point thing
is they're not about you know what you
make time doing what you do is about
their lives actually invest well I mean
you've already changed lives there's no
question about it I mean when you know
we showed you on the network on NFL
Network the other day that video that
went viral of that young girl Giuliana
who you've known for a bit just you know
doing a cartwheel she had the same issue
you did as a child she's without a left
arm entirely pretty much and her able to
do the cartwheel and she's shouting you
out I mean in them and we showed a bunch
of other kids that say that they are you
and I mean you've changed their lives
already she came and for that I say
thank you and congratulations and just
you know you keep doing you essentially
oh yeah definitely I mean I never want
to stop because me do what I do is I
have
go kid do what they want to do otherwise
you know kids are Julian everybody else
I'm not gonna keep doing anything on
that they gonna change they gonna change
the world one day you know I'm glad I'm
glad that me Jim Abbott and everybody
else who passed away Carol I don't care
to be able to change the world
she team always enjoy our chats always
that was great being with your family
that was just awesome and who was the
member of your family that took your
draft card from the table when you
brought your draft card there and forgot
that he was the one who took it and we
started going on a goose chase for like
90 seconds oh my god that happened the
other day brought when oh my god Shakima
Griffon brought his draft card to the
NFL Network set and it went it went
missing
it disappeared yeah and then somebody
basically oh I have it who was that one
of my longtime friends out you know we
were in tracking played ball with it was
like seven years old
Dion Tillis or I die even got it
you probably play my old man machine
leaving he just picked it up there
Harold and he forgot that he had he's
looking through I'm like you were calm
you were so calm you were like okay and
I'm like you know well if we find it
we'll get it and thankfully he had it
but you were so calm I would have been
freaking that was me well you showed it
I saw it firsthand Shakima it's been
great having a front-row seat to your
ascendancy into the National Football
League and go crush it we'll chat down
the line we'll do things for my thank
you for having me always you got it
that's Hakeem Griffith the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience